a mating ritual of the human is a
mind-boggling dance first the male
chooses a mate who is much more
intelligent and attractive than he is
then he begins to obsess over her
consulting her Facebook page up to 50
times a day often pleasuring himself to
her likeness to the point of exhaustion
months can pass with no word from the
mate
then suddenly she will make contact
[Music]
usually when she needs help moving large
objects or when somebody else has
cancelled their plans with her last
minute somewhere in this complex dance
procreation occurs well I got a lot of
notes for starters I think we need 10
more frames of Jeff jerking off to help
with the pacing